i did not think we were going to sit on
the stage and cry oh my god
hello
hello
come on out there look up here look up
here
hi tv
[Music]
this female squeal
i love it
hi hi
everybody it's katie
[Applause]
[Music]
kitten heel is that what they call it uh
it's called a heel for a working
matriarch
can i like skin to skin let's get in the
skin right now it's been so long
the things i've done in vegas there are
things i've done here i would never dare
and i can't believe i got away with that
well that was before cameras all over
everywhere i'll just say that for my
first marriage rihanna threw my
bachelorette party here in vegas so
that's just gonna give you a context
clue and when what year was that i was
24.
and were there cameras around
uh i know not even on our phones we
still like had sidekicks yeah i think
i want to
talk to you about some things that i
discovered there's a vegas legacy and
history in your life
yeah there's like some family
connections here but it's all very
serendipitous synchronicity
almost like i'm living in a simulation
it's so strange because
my aunt um was a top show girl and then
my grandma was the seamstress for that
show
and my dad grew up here met my mom here
who was like a freelance reporter
um they met at a church service that was
being held under a big outside tent that
then was being led by my aunt who used
to be the ex showgirl my parents got
married here but the funny thing is is
that all that happened at a hotel called
the stardust which is what this hotel is
built on basically because they had to
demolish the stardust hotel and then
they rebuilt the resorts world so it's
so so interesting that like out of the
whole strip out of all the hotels like i
would be
kind of performing and putting this show
on on the same grounds that my family
dna has worked on 40 50 60 years ago so
like meant to be it's like it's
definitely it's definitely one of those
signs and symbols moments something
about your grandmother i found out a
detail and will you tell me if it's true
or not that when she was making clothing
for the show girls and
tailoring and doing her thing that she
would find ways inventive ways to create
little pockets even in those tiny thongs
to store women's wedding rings so they
want to get stolen in the 70s
i mean it was like it was vegas was run
by mafia in the 70s you know so my
grandma was the seamstress and there
there were it was topless show girls so
they didn't really have to make tops so
they just wore g-strings
and in that g-string which was the tiny
pocket the wedding ring the wedding ring
i love that
um
and your mom and dad got married here
yes do you know the chapel that they got
married did they get married at a house
like no they got married it's demolished
now it was like a a viewing platform it
was like a needle
like the stratosphere at the
stratosphere that different
um so they got married there
you're engaged i'm engaged okay for a
like a while there was a plan for a
wedding then pandemic then then still i
mean there's still a plan but
the location is challenging well your
parents got married in vegas
i know but i love a big celebration i'm
all about like big fun exotic
great celebrations so hopefully soon i
was so excited to become a mom it was
the one thing i knew i wasn't going to
screw up i'll like crash burn
figure it all out fail because with all
of we were reading the pregnancy book
and it was like your baby is the size of
an olive and that was it that was oh my
gosh really but thank god it was a
papaya
exactly or broccoli or a banana although
i really jet courgette i do love a
courgette and i know that i won't be a
perfect parent because there's no such
thing but i was like i really want to
have my stuff together as much as
possible before i embark on having kids
did you have a perception of what that
journey would be for you yeah i wouldn't
do it did so much work before it because
i was nervous about just some some stuff
i had from my past and i wanted to kind
of clear that
um i wanted to like change all the
energy and um orlando and i were very
intentional on having daisy where we had
decided there was no accident you know
it was time and
daisy is the happiest name it actually
has a smile in it like skippy yeah and
daisy yeah and skippy is a little bit
more like for pets but and boys and
peanut butter but
but
i mean there's a reason since i was 13
that my very favorite word one of my
favorite words in the english language
is daisy yeah the flower the sound of it
she embodies it and it's the best it's
my it's my favorite thing i've ever done
the best job most fulfilling the most
love like i've always had like a like a
um
am i enough
thing hang up you know like um will i be
enough or did i you know just get lucky
or you know i work so hard sometimes to
like prove
am i enough and it's and it comes from a
lot of like childhood stuff
and i i've always had a challenging time
with love and relationships and
um you know maybe not being attracted to
the right kind of people sometimes and i
wanted to be attracted to someone that
was kind and consistent and showed up
for me
and so um i did all the work to do that
and um
it's you know it's paid off i love my
whole life
to learn and grow
and pocket everything i've learned and
when
like
literally the universe as well as the
nurse informed me that i was having
girls
my entire existence made sense for me
did you feel like a
pain when you found out you were having
a girl yeah i mean i never said what i
wanted out loud because i was just gonna
leave it up to the stars but you know
inside there was a little prayer because
i i just
i i love
i love women i love strong women i know
i'm gonna be raising a strong woman i
know all the things that maybe i didn't
get or needed i can give
and so i can kind of like do a little
bit of a redo can i ask you a question
yeah
sometimes i think like i'm just too much
i'm just too much how do you be so much
without feeling like you're too much
balance
i think
obviously there's an onstage persona and
i and i save a lot of that energy for
being on stage and i dial it up i really
love this show that i put on it's my
favorite show it's bringing the most joy
um i'll probably go and make it another
record soon and write it and tour the
world after this which will be so great
but i'm pretty like
even off stage i'm i'm more like
business woman i'm more
i don't talk a lot off stage really no
i'm very kind of like
of an observer i'm an observer and
yeah i like i really save my energy for
when i have to go and turn it on because
when i turn it on it's up to 11 girl
[Music]
you